[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro de ça
c'est passé chaque semaine nous ouvrons
les archives de notre chaîne pour
redécouvrir découvrir quelques-uns des
sujets qui ont marqué l actualité l
locales et dans quelques jours s'ouvrira
une nouvelle édition du mondial de
l'automobile à paris
et pour cette occasion retour sur
l'édition 2004 le département des
yvelines premier département automobile
de france est une nouvelle fois à
l'honneur porte de versailles avec des
constructeurs tels renault ou encore
peugeot et vous allez voir qu'à l'époque
il n'est pas encore question de tout
électrique
tous les modèles exposés ne seront pas
commercialisés mais l'important est d'en
mettre plein la vue et les marques
rivalisent souvent d'idées afin
d'attirer le regard
pour renault la mode us à tout comme les
autres modèles de la firme était
développée au technocentre de guyancourt
une citadine polyvalente dont le secteur
est en pleine progression
à l'intérieur de ce segment c'est vrai
que les attentes ont évolué et le client
ne se contentent plus d'une petite
berline traditionnelle de petites
dimensions ils attendent des prestations
à l'intérieur d'eux
de praticité de vie à bord qui sont
issus des catégories supérieures du set
totalement inspiré de scénic
on a appliqué toutes les bonnes recettes
des monospaces de catégorie supérieure
une voiture de plus petite dimension
sortie le 6 septembre dernier la mode us
est commercialisé au prix de 12 mille
six cent cinquante euros pour la version
de base
de son côté peugeot contre attaque avec
la 1007 en vente dès le 1er trimestre
là aussi une petite voiture dans la même
gamme de prix soit treize mille six
cents euros
les petites voitures c'est un segment
qui est important qui est important non
seulement en france mais où le segment
des petites voitures fait à peu près 38
% du marché total
il peut être beaucoup plus important
dans d'autres pays comme l'italie
puisque en italie on est sur un mix de
55% de petites voitures
donc c'est à quelque chose de très
dynamique c'est un marché très dynamique
qui arrive est complètement en pleine
maturité
peugeot qui dans son bilan 2004 fait
état de deux mille 500 embauches prouve
la bonne forme des constructeurs
français
de son côté la marque au losange annonce
le recrutement de 400 à 500 personnes
pour le site du technocentre
le technocentre qui en parallèle
accueillera prochainement le service
hotline du groupe
grande absente chez renault de ce
mondial de l'automobile 2004 la logan la
citadine qui ne devait être
commercialisée qu'en europe de l'est
sera bien présente en france et ce dès
juin 2005 au prix de 7500 euros
l'annnonce de ce renversement de
situation datant de dimanche dernier
le modèle n'a pu se faire de place aux
côtés de ses grandes soeurs
on quitte le monde automobile pour celui
de la culture nous avons retrouvé
également les images de l'inauguration
du théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines qui se trouve sur la commune de
montigny le bretonneux elle c'était le
27 septembre 1993
une inauguration après trois années de
travaux pour ce qui était à l'époque le
plus grand théâtre jamais réalisée en
ile-de-france ce jour là le public était
accueilli en musique et découvrez ce
nouveau lieu monumentale de création et
de diffusion de la culture qui se
distingue par une architecture originale
mariage de béton brut de pierres et de
métal ainsi que de verre stanislas
filser l'architecte et le scénographe et
michèle riot alec en sont elles les
artisans la place georges pompidou est
alors métamorphosé saint quentin en
yvelines est encore une agglomération
bien jeune et pour le directeur de
l'époque pierre moutarde une telle
aventure a toute sa place ici il y a eu
un travail pendant près de 20 ans à
elancourt
de la part de mes prédécesseurs et de la
part de toute une équipe qui a conduit à
l'existence de ce théâtre
et puis aussi parce que je crois que
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et au delà mérite quel est son
lieu théâtral à 25 ans plus tard le pari
semble plutôt réussi avec une volonté
d'ouverture au plus grand nombre le
théâtre a contribué à donner une âme à
saint quentin en yvelines et regarder
encore ces quelques images qu'on ait le
23 septembre 1993 où l'on voie publique
artistes et élus se côtoyaient on notera
d'ailleurs qu'un tout nouveau préfet
lors de ce moment fait l'un de ses
premiers discours dans le département
assez claude erignac
il restera en poste jusqu'en 1996 et sa
nomination en corse depuis près de 20
ans l'état par action du ministère de la
culture
ce souci de soutenir une action
culturelle qualité au sein de la ville
nouvelle de saint quentin en yvelines
il l'a fait notamment en contribuant
largement à la construction de ce triage
remarquable geste architectural et
écrire c'est lui dire les regrets de
jacques toubon ministre de la culture et
de la francophonie
il va demander d'exécuter son absence et
de vous adresser ses voeux succès et
c'est ainsi que nous refermons ce sas
est passé prochain rendez vous vendredi
prochain tous les anciens numéros sont à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile
[Musique]